I see today in the food industry
a constant need to make a
change in the entire value chain
from where food comes from, how it is
consumed and how it is discarded, and this
needs to make a big change in
people's minds in the way that
business is done because food is
getting more and more expensive and access is more
difficult
one of the ways I see this
happening is with the slow food movement
we use the slow food movement as
a basis for gastronomy but all our
work is to empower people  and
generate skills and life skills
I think this is the future when
you give the voice is the opportunity to act
for the people who are in the field for
the people who work in the
value chain and no longer in the leaders in the owners
of the  companies but the company as a whole
I see society as a
much more holistic and
connected form of operation than a form of
hierarchical power and I see this happening
food can  help people understand
this new moment we are experiencing and
complex changes around the world